so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect hey what's up guys welcome to
dope's usual podcast i am thomas
dopaziola whatever you want to call me i
am here with my co-host marty o'neil
marty's over here with no camera so he
decided to make bird noises i love it i
love it so much guys the reason we're
doing this intro is because like last
time the second jess may gets in the
room we all just start talking about
horrible crazy things and we forgot to
do an intro just started talking so
here's the intro alright this is jessie
may paluso this is her second time on
the show the first female guest we ever
had on the show the first age-restricted
guest we ever had on the show probably
because we're all super vulgar but guys
this is the return of jessica may
palooza we haven't seen in a long time
i'm excited for this episode she just
walked out the door it was hilarious get
ready
escape room and outside my mom's just on
meth going don't you come out of that
[__] room yeah it's just like a house
figure out another way of getting out
eight year old escape room it's just
your bedroom it's like it's just my
childhood yeah it's just my channel my
childhood was my escape room oh my god
yeah let me put some
let me hydrate these lips hydrate
hydration is key let me make sure this
is
off that's off do you want to off off no
it's up to you airplane mode do you need
that i just put the [__] on silent
[__] on silent i believe so yeah we
have a new mascot in the corner if you
see our gremlin flashing gremlin over
there oh [__] i found this [__]
that's the 80s icon he really flashes he
doesn't have a dick but he really
flashes you can mold his arms and he
holds his junk open it's pretty cool
that's dark it's so cool though that the
gremlins don't have dicks
well they reproduce by water
so they don't need to be [__] that's
weird
that's some real puritanical [__]
that's a that's a way for a pervert to
be perverted without being perverted
they're like how can we make them [__]
let's get them wet oh
it's still kind of gross so weird it's
really gross i'll [__] with a furby that
was the original oh furbies
they were like little toys right yeah
but they looked just like the original
magua grimlock the big eyes
before he got we had cute toys in the
80s there's a place called
frankenstein's i've been going to
it has collectible toys from every area
you could think of
did you say frankincense
frank and sun i was like
i'm like that sounds like a witch no
it's the size of a costco a pen it's a
toy store it's only open three days a
week one guy has 80s toys one guy has
90s toys one guy has movie only
one guy has like football stuff and this
stuff it's [__] incredible
it sounds like a secret society thing
it's as big as a costco it's running
somebody hannah in uh pomona how was
that not a great day
i i don't know but benihana and 90s toys
why do you park what do you do just keep
the car neutral and just kind of go
around the mountain
and i got an uber
because there's signs on every block
saying frankenstein
no it'll say frankincense parking tow so
if you park anywhere within a mile in
any parking lot they will tell your ass
that's really strange it's almost like
they set it up to be very difficult a
hundred percent
yeah last weekend i circled like 30
minutes like i'm not driving three miles
and getting another uber how often do
you go my mom's boyfriend's a [__]
nerd kinda like in a good way so he goes
and i'll just go with his ass
oh i love toys i love toys
i have a toy collection
but good [__] like dope [__] have we
started have you recorded no you got all
your [__] hold on i got my [__] together
i know how you i know you like to creep
in on these episodes oh yeah you know
creep and creep out you know my style
i want you know what toy i have that
i've kept
um an urkel doll nice and you pull it
and it does all like the didn't i do
that you want any cheese my sister had
the uh
me herman one i had pee wee remember one
too gray suit yeah i mightn't had yes it
did have a grace and cherry when you
go like this in the back and she
talks
no no it's a chair gotcha yeah yeah yeah
and you put your hand to make it work i
didn't have that i just had people
herman i watched people here when he
just started jerking it and then he was
gone you that's when you got into pb
hermann no right before that and then my
aunt had
yeah it said masturbate and i had a
picture of you herman like why i love
that guy and then he was on tv no more
isn't that crazy it's like not that he
should have
he was an adult in an adult place he was
an adult and adult place and i'm not
saying i'm not saying anything but it's
the way we take people down
is so hypocritical
it's so it's almost for show he heard no
one
cancel him like oh [__] we don't want
the guy talking to our kids just out
about pete i guarantee you bob ross was
[__] oh and ver and bob ross had some
anger yeah bob roberts he's blowing
motherfucker's heads off what do you
mean i mean he was like happy little
trees it felt like he was containing
anger while he oh yes i thought she
meant there was an article about that
bob ross posthumously i'm done with
society no they did that for me dr seuss
last time we asked you oh real quick
they preemptively did it ready yeah you
were our first female guest we ever had
on the show and our first age-restricted
episode of all time
is it because of me it's because of the
[__] we talked about
that's when we realized we can't put
crazy titles anymore yeah
squirting on stamos that was it
youtube was like yo you're brand new
don't be [__] around like that's
right keep your [__] kids at home oh
[__] you want to hang out with jessie
may
and dope you got to just stay at home
with the children or get a babysitter
babysitters are great they're great they
are out there they exist have you ever
babysat
i've raised my little brother basically
when i was a kid but other than that no
yeah i mean at every family party
mexican people don't watch their [__]
kids so i'm like yo
you're gonna die come over here you're
gonna [__] get killed over there so
i'm like the
don't die babysitter but i'm not sitting
there watching you yeah you're not like
actively
no but if i'm outside i will have to
watch the babies like kill your comments
somewhere and the cows bodyguard yeah
i'm just picturing some like big dude
like with a shaved head and arm tattoos
just standing at the pool watching the
kids it's hard that'd be a cool way to
have like a bait like a bodyguard oh
yeah
that's a business that's a business
marty you might want to get into that
[__] the last man i entered in that [__]
at a young age
i used to get i used to babysit for this
one woman she paid me in beer and weed
stop i would just show up like you need
a babysitter how were you i was like 16.
oh my god i was like why don't you go
someplace why don't you leave you ladies
every parent wants that by the way
somebody just show up and offer to wash
their kids who does it right
wow and you just hand over what you
already have in your adult pants yeah so
basically you were just gonna get high
and make sure that they didn't die yeah
i i got yes yeah allegedly you really
have to do much i think they're still
alive they think the children are still
okay that's all that matters really i
think they're fine i'm pretty sure now
they're getting high in baby soon
shout out to tara
no i didn't have a babysitter my
babysitter was a
don't you [__] move and watch tv wow
that was pretty much yeah it's so wild
like how we grew up
i don't know about you but i was out in
the street oh yeah until the until the
street lights came on lights came on
yeah and you were out with children
unsupervised
and guess what
you couldn't come back in either you
couldn't come back in the house no your
mom would be like you stay until that
[__] electricity kicks on you stay in
kick rocks and we survived
some of us might have gotten stolen
but you know we survived police
the process of elimination that gets
stupid that is [__] up it's [__] up
there's this one time it's very true and
it's it really is a
the real pandemic in this country and in
many other countries is what goes on
with children
and
if we want to get into like we won't get
too deep into it because we like to keep
it light i think um i think i truly
think that obviously there's real news
that goes on but i do believe a lot of
what is being infiltrated into our feed
is to keep us distracted from what's
really going on and what people are
really doing every day it's not a new
thought right i think it's where there's
shoot shows and tv and movies all these
distractions so that the players can
play um but i remember this one time
when i was a kid i was probably like
eight years old
and my girlfriend and i were just
playing in the front yard in the
summertime you know it was probably like
six o'clock at night and this white
van pulls up couldn't get any more
stereotypical
and the dude says what do you think the
dude says
i know you're mom
hop in that was the thing they told me
at school good ones that would have been
a good one always said i don't you don't
know my mom i know my mom's friends
that's pretty psychological like your
mom's oh your mom needs to pick you up
she got hurt let's go that's one thing
that you should tell us at school and
when i was live down here like what a
stranger what a stranger would say
because the kid's gonna be my mom and
hop in
what would be the second thing you would
go to you guys want to go to the movies
you want some money
i don't know candy
oh i thought that was too gentle he said
he he said he was so generic he said he
had candy
and my girlfriend and i were like well
we have it too in the house
so we're good
like we didn't even think anything of i
remember i like as an adult remembering
it i remember
not feeling threatened just being like
well we're we're okay we don't need your
car candy
but a mat because i was loved but
children who are missing just a little
bit
like the the the recipe's just a little
off
they're gonna go towards whatever that
thing is you just don't have that thing
in your brain yet that that danger
mechanism at that age right and it's not
just missing love because parents do
love their children and things happen
but it's so [__] so i get why parents
are like helicopters i got in a car with
a stranger as a kid one time you did
why yeah i walked to the corner store by
myself it was one of the first times i
ever walked by myself i was young young
white boy blonde blue eyes yeah you're
right i was feeling myself i had a
little gray uh
basketball uniform starter jacket went
down i'm walking and there's this
vicious rottweiler on the other side of
the street as i'm getting closer to the
corner store and it's on what looked to
me like a tiny little chain it's
freaking out like really really freaking
out at me terrified me i was on the
other side of the street i walked past i
got to the corner store and i was too
scared to walk back
so i'm like pacing around in front of
the store i'm calling my gram's house on
the pay phone nobody's answering and
then the lady that worked at the store
noticed me kind of lurking around the
front of the store and she's she offered
to give me a ride home and i got in her
car that's different i mean i thought
you were going to get mad
what a great horror movie twist the old
lady picks up the kid the story is not
over yeah
oh the story just took me home
what a twist what is this night
movie it is except they get shitty over
time i had a woman get in my car once
randomly i'm in i'm driving through
lackawanna i'm on the bridge i'm on the
slum side of the bridge i'm waiting out
of light
high out of my mind like paranoid to
begin with in my dad's green station
wagon it's snowing the doors freeze open
on the regular so i would be driving
holding the doors closed on the regular
like holding the passenger door shut on
this day i'm at this light this woman
just gets in the car she wasn't like
homeless but it was snowing
and she was older
so she just gets in and just sits down
wow and i'm like
already kind of
freaked out just in my estate that i'm
in and i'm like what the [__] is going
on part of me is like
it's a the normal thing to do would be
to just take this woman where she's
going
she's an old woman
but then the other part of me is like
this [__] just got in my car and not
say a word i'm like no but she was just
talking like she was talking
like what was she saying she was saying
some crazy [__] about her ex-husband
some oh was she fleeing no she was just
talking normally like we knew each other
and she was saying that she needed to go
to cvs down the street or whatever
that's my [__] she's just like look
she's getting dropped i'm chilly
i'm chilly
was she a little was she thin no she was
like an old lady she was like
i don't know she had a jacket on she
wasn't she grandma from the hook then if
you're old and thin and it's winter it's
hard you need circulation yeah i didn't
want to leave you but still like it
happened so [__] quick i'm thinking
i'm on point this lady just gets in my
car yo that's scary
i love that his car stories are like
unhostile older women nothing actually
happens but it's weird yeah that's all
one time i got picked one time a car
picked me up the lady brought me to
guys that's it
that's the best story i'm like a grown
man trying to steal me off my mom's
mom's right now you got candy one old
lady gave me a scholarship one time
i don't know that's where the story ends
i thought it was gonna be and he just
wanted some company
it was weird because i was so high to
begin with i remember i had like a loose
can of lights all in the car i remember
a loose so you can see loose candle
lights off it's such a weird sentence
oh you're right it's secured down it's
in the bag
it's something i just had it i had it
like a loose sandwich
it was a weapon at that point first of
all i had i had it defend off getting
pulled over that lights all can't turn
into a weapon the minute this [__] got
in the car
no you mean that's why i remembered it
i've never heard that stuck on it i've
never heard i just don't know how else
it is
they're all loose
no no when you have a can of lice on
your car it's generally in the context
of a grocery bag
but what is it in the grocery bag it's
still loose in the mask
this thing's just [__] rolling
you might want to check the receipt you
might want to check the recipe on your
dad yo you guys ever been to oregon and
they had that paul bunyan statue
i went when i was like four it just
reminded me of all these memories who
said that right now yeah that's just not
that fun
that's all i have to say about it
it's just you know your posture
and cadence in tone
really offered a different delivery
everything we say is that guys you
[__] ready for this
there's nothing never mind this just did
here's a memory that's not going to
bring us to any story or conclusion the
guy that was doing the voice kept
hitting my aunt i thought it was so odd
it's a [__] statue hitting on my aunt
i was like four years old wait what do
you mean the guy there's a there's a
voice all right um and the guy does it
for the microphone from the building
okay now that's a job i want that's a
job i would have gotten and been fired
the same day oh for sure
hey [__]
done 40 seconds after i'm out
that sounds like a [__] netflix show
if you ask that's fun that would be fun
that would be a practical joke or [__]
yeah i used to work at h m and we had a
god mic you know to make announcements
of a store your kids missing and there's
like blood in in the lawn in the
lingerie department whatever we'd have
to say and at the end of the night when
they clean up they'd let me like just
loose on the god mic so i would do like
late night dj and play music for my
phone when everybody was like cleaning
and then i call out people who were lazy
during the day and gerald who was just a
[__] of a [__] of a manager
like it i wish you well gerald's not a
very peaceful fun name it's not a gerald
how many geralds do you know are kind if
you if your name is gerald then you go
by gerald you're kind i'm so i don't
want to say is that is it is this what
makes it have a parental advice is there
six gerald's watching like yeah i mean
was that on the episode where we were
talking about her first episode were we
recording
it was right what do you what did you
just say
wait can you i don't know i was hoping
that was like shorthand uh-uh i didn't
get it we were talking about her first
episode was the first age-restricted
episode yeah we did all right gotcha
yeah now that makes sense i don't know i
don't remember we were recording there's
only a rapper here yeah
no i had to come back around and circle
back around sorry my words man i have a
really sad story for you oh my god
do you want to join
yeah before we would you like a joint no
no yeah i mean always but um your push
trees bong shattered on my kitchen floor
i'll give you another one how hard did
you drop it
well if you didn't if okay now you
ruined
that not ruined it but it would have
been such a different experience had you
not told me about josh wolfe going into
a k hole over the children's laughter oh
sorry just made some mushrooms before we
started and happened i don't know as
sweet she said i'm not dumb that's smart
for any guests
like this if there's fluorescent
graffiti on the wall you got to let them
know that you [__] yeah
yeah
yeah thomas found thomas
did mushrooms for the first time solo on
the podcast right
yeah mushrooms and i always do mushrooms
in this in the dark of my room with no
music because it's really fun yeah it
sounds good for you but the first time i
did it in the day
with other people was on the show and
that [__] got wild okay that's different
oh it was hard to articulate what the
next sentence i was going to say and
then marty had to do the ad reads
because i could not [__] continue
like
i couldn't do [__]
you couldn't tell people to keep their
dicks clean and some landscapes marty
just had to do it
i tried and everything in my body kept
making me like
mushrooms
um sorry very sad story
sad story and i went oh man this is a
bad move milk was a bad choice milk was
a bad show i just watched the other day
um so the bong broke
throw it to the ground yeah cause that
[__] is the thickest bong in the world
it's such a thick bong look it didn't
break break is like a snap
if you break something
just spike it like uh you hit it bro
it broke like it broke by like some
frequency i can't hear
really yeah i don't know what happened
that's a 10 millimeter thick glass it's
so thick [__] sniper tried to take
you out because it's so thick
the [__] came through my window bro
because it's so thick the mouth the the
um
the pipe part
shattered and went like through through
the wall into my neighbors
you're not no oh my god say no [__]
way
i just imagine that man
i have to talk to the manufacturers
about this no it's it was my fault it
was a user problem for sure it's a
beautifully built bong i just i'm a i'm
a i got you i got you another hennessy
shapes i didn't have the hennessy rakes
they're [__] cool drop it in the
comments do all people that smoke weed
go through glass pieces like
frequently okay
am i so i'm not the only one no
i don't know i felt like oh my god i
just can't life right i feel like there
shouldn't be glass in the first place
that's where we're my friend no glasses
class is key for flavor yeah it's the
way to go but breakability we gotta i
need bubble wrap or some [__] yeah we
need something we need like a
we need something to help us i don't
know what that would be
a bouncy house
we all live in a [__] cause you know
what had i lived in a bouncy house that
[__] still be bouncing that's
true
grab it on the up like the things on the
waiting list on the tv like the first
video game ever
what was that called pong pong
[__] would be pink
damn
oh my gosh something to my tongue
oh my god found the clip clip it
did you even have any respect to look at
my feet
what all the wu-tang things are the
first thing i [__] noticed when you
got out of the car
come on you walked out with mutang are
those crocs these are
limited
editions come on croc slides i saw when
you got i'm like dude come on now god
girl's shoes are always going to reign
over dudes so so they're so much better
pull these off of course you could pull
these off going to the store
you could pull these you could get it
asked what gang are you from no [__]
i'm in the children's gang [__]
protect your neck and also your liver
and also your head and your lungs your
liver if you watch that last ufc protect
your [__] liver this dude is that
what you were referring to no i just was
saying like you know it's funny to be so
hard yeah it's like on the other side of
being like a gang banger i wonder if
there's like this
concern of health you're like protect
your neck [__] but also like get
some kale get a colonoscopy have a
smooth have a smoothie check in with
your
what happened at ufc
i don't know i don't follow it but no
somebody was finished with a brutal kick
to the liver that you don't his body
just shut off you don't normally see
that did he die i don't think he died
but he definitely lost the fight
i mean they lose the fight with life or
the fight with the fight as he left the
octagon he was alive i would have heard
about it if he died but his body shut
off it wasn't even that brutal of a kick
it's just that right spot in the living
room
can they do that can they can they kick
in the liver i feel like that should be
a limitation if you can't eye gouge and
like yeah no ball crap
what recently huh you finally got sick
ugh ugh you're better now you know
here's okay so have you heard the theory
that smokers haven't gotten covered
i got this yet you got it yeah that's
your like you're navigo i've heard it i
and i forced myself to believe it and i
didn't look at anything countering that
ideology so i could live in that
doctrine completely
and i was filming in greece for a month
couldn't find weed let me ask you a
question
you're an island
and you don't grow weed you're not
islanding right
no why do you why do you live on a
[__] island isn't it
to do drugs and look at the sunset
you got [__] goats
you ain't got no weed i would chill with
goats heavy bro you ever chill the goat
sober what do you talk about no i
haven't what are you talking about
finance mainly
they're workhorses but they're goats
this is we really have to plan your
international travel yeah it's really a
topic on the podcast lately well because
it's like okay we look at what's
happening with the wnba girl yeah
bianca what's her name i actually wrote
it down because i wanted to ask you
about it britney greener greener britney
greener something like that yeah or
something like that and you know so
ideally you want to like plan your
international travel well if you're a
smoker you want to like have some supply
to sort of like
bleed you into their supply and then
maybe that's what i do i usually have
like a little bit
allegedly and then
get in with the locals and then have a
little bit for when i come out
and i didn't do that in greece i just
was like actually i take it back i did
have a bag of adipose nice i did but i
[__] love to smoke edibles are great
it's a different situation it's like
water like i need to eat but i need to
drink water yeah it's this is ceremonial
this edibles feels you can't do this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
watching a movie i am not at least
edibles aren't like a vibe no
so i had edibles and then i got there
and there and i i was asking everybody
i'm like where's your weed where's your
weed where'd you eat i learned that [__]
and greek forgot it now but it's like
don't stop how many how much edibles uh
does it take to have you feel
it [__]
two milligrams really i'm so i'm so
light that's awesome
and
micro doses do a lot to me
and i don't you know it's all about your
intent like what do you want out of the
experience like do you want to like
float or do you want to just like have
your tippy toes so you're talking about
you open the bag you eat one little
gummy out of it and you feel it yeah i
feel what i need to feel or what i want
to feel and if i want to feel more i
just take a little bit more but for the
most part i just like to kind of like
coast a little i like to like bounce a
little bit
um and i had you know i was working so
i'm like i need something where i can
just sort of like
maintain
uh
and i finally found these dudes at this
one restaurant
to verna oasis overlooking how did you
bring it up
what you just went up to dudes at
restaurant you got weed yeah because
that was so good you're talking to me
i was so done
but like three weeks in i'm like
three weeks in yeah
so you just
changed you had enough last three weeks
oh yeah but i only had edibles oh that's
okay that's all i had damn in cbd they
sell cbd
not the same i saw these two dudes
there's one restaurant taverna oasis
overlooking the ionian sea and they all
said their name was thomas i'm like
[__] look at me in the face you
think that's gonna work on my ass i know
i'm a white blond [__] but i know your
name's not thomas hey my name is thomas
won't buy something
that's where they got it from just
kidding you do [__] yeah
my name is
thomas all four of them
and i was like look he served me this
he's like here's a free shot and it was
like fuchsia colored and it tastes like
something you clean your windows with
and
and j ghb
the [__] i just gave you a shot
red lake 45 we're all named thomas
right like what am i being entered into
a secret greek society yes
and the shot was [__] and i said where's
your weed
he was like what i'm like are we quit
all of you are [__] around
where's the weed
he was like okay i got some in the
garden and i'm like okay
he goes just leave us a review on the on
the website shut the [__] up you could
read my review it's for to burn oasis oh
weed shop
no no no
this [__] let me tell you okay so i left
a review
he came back with like a receipt folded
up
and he had leaves in it and it looked
like he snipped up some basil and
oregano
and just put it in a receipt but you
know like the power of your mind
desperation yeah damn you convinced
yourself
on it yeah i sprinkled that [__] into my
cbd joint and i'm like okay this is all
i got
and just let it did it do it
your brain wanted it to it wasn't so bad
[__] thomas [__] making me look
bad what the hell like if you're going
to island island right you heard this
about hawaii too last episode yeah i had
a couple homies go to hawaii recently
they're like the weed is just trash we
have a friend shout out to trent
chandler's out there he tells me like
wow all you need is the sunshine right
oh yeah
is it a weed smoking culture yes but
not the fire i guess
yeah and that's cool it's like another
country that's a different thing oh we
weren't going to talk about brittany
where were you what you want to talk
about what's up with that
yeah but
if you're going to russia for me to you
yeah are you bringing weed i i'm not i'm
not even going to bring a thong thank
you i am going to leave my beliefs at
home
russia
i'm not even bringing a smile yeah it
doesn't look like they wear them often
i'm going to walk in a marching form
everywhere i go and i'm out yeah okay so
you agree with me like yo what were you
thinking you were seven foot tall i do
agree but i also think
how well they don't play that [__] over
there i feel like and i know you feel
this
it's if people get outraged over this
and we have so many people that are
imprisoned here
no one gets outraged
not that you're not i'm saying
like what it is like an american in
another country trapped
that's what they're thinking
athlete
we need a female she doesn't need to get
she doesn't get back it's ridiculous
that's [__]
been there five months now isn't there
exchange can't exchange they're gonna
exchange a man what was the guy's name
you've both
his nickname was so [__] up like
you're trading people
this is getting a little yeah are we
opening a strange it's getting a little
weird here this is a slave trade yeah
what's going on what's happening right
now i don't like it what are they trying
to do they're like look it feels like
they're dangling a carrot like this poor
girl and rightfully so like of all the
countries right now you want to be
locked up she's not back that is [__]
[__] scary remember locked up abroad
oh yeah that that show horrifying
how did you never watch it when did it
come out rod
2 000. it's been out for like 20 [__]
years i've never seen this people who
travel internationally and have drugs on
them and then of course
they are
you know become the the
completely
having to deal with the country's rules
they have to succumb to what those
countries rules are based off of thank
you let me tell you we're pretty [__]
liberal compared to the rest of the
world bro
some take heads i could walk down the
street and just go a [__] and do
whatever i want that's we're pretty free
and open here yeah but there's some
places where literally like you have to
protect your neck because you will lose
it if you say something cross about the
president it's so weird huh it's so for
her for the culture shock of her she's
in a cell in russia in russia the
tallest person in the country
no bed is suitable for her over there
if i were i'd be worried about
russia wanting to use her dna to create
like a super
weapon
like a cr like like create my brain
didn't go there yet i'm not mushrooms
either so maybe that's why i'm thinking
in movies right yeah that's the movie
[__] i mean they don't have rules what's
stopping them from doing some crazy i
see stranger things going crazy
i hope she gets home soon soon i really
do and i hope everybody else in this
country who are still incarcerated for
cannabis crime i think it's coming soon
how much coverage how much weed did she
have like she had a vape she had it was
one pen and it was like a small it was a
cartridge it wasn't even attached to a
pen i don't think i could be wrong it
that's all she had
she's tripping for bringing it but also
she shouldn't have been worried that
hard that she'd gone in an international
news but also
isn't there a conversation that
they're they're um assistant coaches
coaches
medical staff isn't someone like
reiterating this to them because i'm
sorry when you're
you know she probably has a lot going on
in her life and she's also like a
successful black female athlete
she can't be expected it no
everything keep track of what the rules
are like let's re hey these are things
we're traveling
they're traveling to russia
i don't even know when it's not a
chaotic time to travel there and what
parts you can or can't not travel to
let alone someone like her who's busy
playing games and having to like be on
her
best
athletic performance like maybe maybe
like print out a sheet yeah don't make
sure you don't have this make sure we do
that [__] on camping trips in the fifth
grade yeah they didn't do it for that
girl was kind of [__] up yeah for the
team like hey this is what could get you
arrested and make you stay in russia yes
she doesn't know that that should be on
the top of the list forget like
obviously it wasn't the olympics is this
like the wnba or
it was a wnba i think so wasn't it we
all
we should know we all don't we're all
adults there's a [__] laptop in front
of you i'm just trying to see if we can
figure this out i thought she was a
college athlete can i google it
what's her name brittany garrett grayner
marty's got it
brittany griner you were right
that's just crazy
wnba let's see is his number oh yeah
mercury
she played for phoenix mercury are they
going to russia why are we going to
russia can't we go to idaho
isn't there like a fun team in idaho oh
they're tall girl in idaho are we
exhausted why do we gotta look during a
war
yeah i would think maybe we don't go to
russia you know what i mean to play
basketball i have no idea what was
happening
that's the face
that's how i felt when i just heard it
hey guys you know on the docket
is the ukraine struggling to get
breath
we're headed to russia struggling to get
my videographer is from russia straight
from russia and he tells me all the [__]
behind him like
coward dumb
we're so dumb why are we fighting each
other this is the dumbest [__] we're as
humans you mean yes we're so [__]
stupid
it's so much more fun
to let go of everything
and be children
but at some point along our lifeline we
adult the child out of us and we get
sucked into the game we get sucked into
the jumanji the jumanji
and the you know never-ending rat race
that it is and we it's almost like we we
hyper speed
the [__] away from our truth and what
we're like as children
it's true but some kids [__] suck too
that's true to say that right now but
it's like right i want i see that
i got a 14 year old an eight-year-old
four-year-old i'm seeing all that happen
right sam yeah i'm not here i thought
you were going to keep going
marty's got a small team actually but
it's like yeah
they are themselves right now and it's
like
you know at a certain point now it's
like at what point do you
have to like get after it in life and
like do what you got to do to make it
but it
having a dream is expensive
on all levels emotionally financially
spiritually
uh familially it's very expensive it's
just not spanish yeah
really
she's yeah i know she's all multilingual
now she took a trip she knows how to say
what's up with the weed and greek weed
and greece i'm basically trilingual
i want food right now oh is that in what
greek i don't know oh she came from the
source
no hold on now
fill us in so fill us in i went to
school with her
wow that's
[__] work at first i thought you were
gonna say i don't know why i thought
phyllis diller first thing i thought of
when you said that word no frozen
pillar
i like that
you were filming in greece right yeah
for a month yeah for what um
is it your new show that you're doing
yeah a hosting show out there yeah they
don't got americans with bad tattoos
too they're like yo let's go to greece
they got no weed and [__] tattoos is it
a coincidence it's not about tattoos
it's a different show i can't say what
it is but oh it's a different [__] it's
a different show oh okay
yeah yeah
[Music]
are they [__] serious and i'm like
that was entertaining actually i don't
know how to find john stamos in every
town in greece
to just get closer to him my ex and him
are best friends uh giannis
are you [__] have you ever read
janason no you would love him yeah his
papas he's a comedian you're very funny
him he's a great pappas what does that
sound familiar you probably heard of him
he's got a podcast he's on the podcast
i'm not in any way shape or form saying
that i'm saying too mean is he kind of
like a taller goofy looking white dude
no aren't they all
no because martin's name one that's not
who's not a taller looking goofy white
dude that's a comedian name go ahead
name one oh that's a comedian i'll take
it all back
you're right who's not you're right even
of white anthony white dudes all walk
like like shag
conor mcgregor they all walk like shaggy
from [__] scooby doo okay like when
they're [__] telling jokes yes papa's
is like not a white dude though right
now he's great i have no idea and that's
why him and stamos are thick as thieves
cause greeks you know they stick
together it's cute i just realized who
this person was in my head yeah i've
seen his podcast before long glasses now
yeah yeah glasses yeah i know exactly i
saw him on [__] tick-tock he's pretty
damn funny yeah he's very smart very
funny yeah okay yeah is that why you got
with him
played the long cardigan she's got a
couple degrees of separation she's been
working the [__] yeah i'm [__]
working the greek system
dating
[Music]
we just connected them like a mutual
level and then i was like my wonderful
you know stay moved
this will be my ticket to stay exactly
getting greasy what happened
what happened he doesn't know him what
i'm saying what happened he never
introduced you to him no no john knew of
me because i publicly talk about him
everybody says our episode
single time
no he would like respond to texts and
stuff he's funny he has a great sense of
humor about himself and now it's become
like a bigger thing than it's like
taking on its own thing it's funny i
think it's so funny he's such an icon
but yeah i like that you just made him
yours
you stole his ass
he's [__] mine
i like that oh speaking of people that
you own
um
bro
yes now i sound but now i was gonna say
i sound like i own people but since
you're naming greg i'm saying it like
that because i know you like brad pitt i
do there was a art i saw a picture of
him on a magazine and he looked like a
[__] interview with a vampire i'm
saying like take a bite no no like not
in the coolest why i say it you make a
bite like low iron like he needs some
iron protect your neck and take your
iron capsule yes
low iron there's a picture of him on a
magazine recently you got to find it
he's like this
he looks like a corpse it was a i think
it was an artistic
i guess i i don't know i haven't seen it
okay you haven't seen it can you look at
it i have to turn around tell me when
you're ready not yet not yet see that's
gonna get a tv right there
go ahead
he looks like he might say don't tell me
don't tell me
i'm not wrong i'm not wrong
i bet they took ten thousand photos that
day it looks like he does horse track
racing
and he re-gifts on christmas
that's not that's that's him
oh that's him
that picture scares the [__] out of me
that's a different dude they explain
themselves what's with the [__]
lizard how are you gonna do that to that
i need to go from there he looks like a
he looks like a seven-year-old woman
who's going as brad pitt
we should cut that out because he looks
like a gym team he does like a gym a gym
teacher
is this for some is there a reason i
think it's just for gq it doesn't there
doesn't need to always be a reason but
when it's this we need a i need to know
donation i need an
explanation because you can't be like yo
that's what i look like every other day
oh and then some days they just look
like this
oh yeah they had to be going for a look
like we want to make you look like all
[__] up
how can we destruct brad pitt
how can we make average dudes go this is
the [__]
how can we dry up how can we cause a
female drought yeah can we get jessica
to stop harassing brad pitt there it is
right [__] there
you look like my uncle now
there's a list oh yeah donald trump on
your list get down on your list okay so
brad pitt give me something brad pitt
are you you're just like are you stuck
you sound like a stuck seed
what'd you do
bread
scary
you like it i don't got my turntable
sounded kind of the [__]
oh so what were you doing to pass the
time when you were sick that's how high
we are
we asked that 40 minutes ago
i said how scary was that that was good
oh we were kept we were buttoning it we
got it we got it we're just pretty
scared yeah i just wanted to show you
i'm shocked you haven't seen that
i'm kind of mad that now i it's in my
zeitgeist
yeah
maybe you're just trying to divert me
now i'm wondering why yeah distractions
are you into brad pitt we're working for
stainless i'm brad pitt's assistant i've
been this whole time i've been blocking
you on every account
his real account he's not even on social
media you think
because i've blocked you on everything
that's not exactly
standing
next
to jesus christ
yo what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about one of our longtime
sponsors and that's us all right this ad
read is brought to you by pushtrees.com
hopefully all you guys know already but
if you didn't i own a clothing company
called push trees we are coming up on
our ninth year anniversary odd to say
that out loud but to anyone that's ever
bought a shirt said hi to me in person
left a comment or anything any
positivity i appreciate you so anyway we
just wanted to throw in this little
insert this ad read for pushtrays.com
because we don't do it enough marty was
like you know what let's drop a push
trees in this episode we just dropped
new shirts we have sweaters we have
trays we have little rigs grinders
everything you can think of go to
pushtrees.com anything like i said if
you don't buy anything leave it a
comment leave it a like that is support
thank you for supporting the brand that
got us here thank you guys so much back
to the episode
yo
new show
what's up new show tattoo redo
you gotta show out and brad pitt doesn't
right now tattoo
how
the show i did in greece no no no no no
oh with him
what we're talking about you're actually
i don't know i just saw you yeah for
netflix oh i'm tattoo redo that was from
like a uh over a year ago we haven't
seen you in almost two years
you really came in the very very
beginning you were the second or third
person on the show
third person on the show wow yeah we
haven't seen you at all oh my gosh yeah
so i was like i'm like oh my first
netflix show is so long
i haven't seen you at all but i saw him
like wait
what the [__] is going on we haven't
seen her and now she's on netflix doing
a show i just want to ask about it oh
yeah so you're just staring at
[__] going i'm sorry yeah are
you happy
it's amazing like what people put on
them on their bodies it's the worst
thing you saw
that pause
uh this woman who was really delightful
mother of five
had
um her back done in giant black bold
letters across
from hip to hip and it said [__] you
[Music]
did you ask her why she got it i just
asked her why she's so mad
so he cheats on me a lot and he's gonna
[__] remember like what got you so
mad girl
but she was delightful and she ended up
getting something different that was the
whole point everyone got their tattoos
covered up did she cover it with birds
i guess so i was like [__] you birds
[Laughter]
if i said the type of bird it would have
sounded so much nicer but i was like
burnt
that's the way you said it like [__]
i initially thought of the birds you had
wait am i tripping what i got a bird i
got out yeah that's just awesome it's a
bird of prey
she should have got that on her back
yeah that would have been pretty dope
owl picking up oh i'm here for a dragon
i'm here for a dragon or dragon going
around the letter so it just looks sick
yeah [__] you dragon on it
is it just a dragon hanging on to [__]
you yeah why cover it up spice it up
that's your problem
your problem is you don't you're not
adding any spices this [__] you needs a
little picante it's something
i mean i'm gonna be honest that'd be a
hard asset to dragon going in the [__]
you i mean it could it's
slightly gangster you could lean
gangster with a dragon
but i'm saying you're a [__] mom of
five it's a vibe yeah being a gangster
and a mama five yeah that's a vibe but
there was definitely like a lot of some
people sat for
over 10 hours getting tattooed because
the cover-ups are always going to be big
at least bigger did you get any
cover-ups did you know i got tattoos i
got i got a rose on the show on the show
and then the girl who did this her name
was isrose she did this owl for me oh
okay but off the show do you have any
that uh
you would like to get covered up do you
have any other tattoos i have a
transparent dumb one i got a [__] stamp
what i'm from upstate new york though
that's like a birth certificate yeah no
they put those on yeah yeah you get that
little footprint and then they
yeah this one has an owl
it's a bird of prey
i'm such a nerd oh my god see if i don't
say it it'll be in my head all day and
i'll be mad i think i heard his [__]
ass owl no it's out there
bunnies and chips
oh my god i just went to new york
recently for the first time visited you
guys estate
it's two on one over here you didn't
visit our state you went to new york
city i know i wasn't used to our state i
was in the state that's not the state
but it's true i was in your state you
got to drive out to the middle of
nowhere
i'm from there you asked new yorkers if
they're part of new york state they
think new york city is the only thing
that exists in new york meanwhile
upstate new york is the entirety of the
state and it's so beautiful and it
doesn't get it's like michelle and in in
destiny's child
oh like new york city's beyonce
yeah and upstate is michelle yeah she's
still great she's still great
but they're like who don't act like
she's not here doing [__]
maybe i should say kelly i should
probably say kelly no i i downplayed
upstate new york it's kelly rowland
thank you that's true it's kelly rollins
michelle yeah it's kelly rowland and
salon
sorry michelle you came up bumping that
song so loud and you're like the new
beyonce yeah or whatever you said when
you got off the couch
i'm breaking my speakers at first i
thought it was the neighbors like [__]
they're bumping i bump it i bump it the
renaissance
album this is me listening to it brad
pitt
i'm brad pitt i'm like this
and here's a lizard
is there a wizard on the chip was there
a lizard on his chest there's a [__]
lizard on his chest bro what's this i
saw the hand with a little blood drop
like what gang are you in uh what what's
your subliminal illuminati
have you ever in your life when you're
your most coziest never been up in life
nope never been like but i have been
upside down on the couch a lot of times
that's fun yeah gravity fun what's this
that's dumb
this is like some illuminati that's what
that's what i'm saying yeah that's what
you do when you recently get engaged
you do this a lot yeah it's [__]
illuminati [__] what are they trying to
say to us we need sam tripoli to decode
that magazine cover jesus christ it's
the lizard purple yeah he's clearly a
[__] lizard person
yeah that's not my sister like a [__]
spiderman's uh boss that was good at the
daily bugle
okay
that was my generic
alex jones is going to be 30 years later
i'm like this man was on he was the man
he thought of everything before you knew
yep that's i think so too because he is
crazy he's crazy [__] starts to come to
life
outliers are the ones that have the
truth i think that's why they become
outliers people don't like the truth
people can't handle the truth even the
simplest truths humans have a hard time
handling yeah of course i i tell that to
my kids like i talk to my kids the the
questions you're asking me people have
asked this [__] every person that's ever
lived has wondered this [__] and there's
a lot of wonky [__] in place in our
world because people are so scared of
the most basic [__] they're so scared of
it why are we here like
chill
it's grand theft auto yeah and it is
grand theft auto it's grant the world is
grand theft auto and the cheat codes are
manifestation think in your head what's
gonna happen and that's what i think
that was a very profound thought
explaining life burped at me like a
[__] disney cartoon
continue
[Laughter]
tiger king
that's what it was yeah
after the fire and he's like i will
never financially recover from this it's
my favorite thing to say that's
incredible yeah we saw you right before
right when that was happening that's
right it was during quarantine like
last time you were here remember how
much fun we thought tiger king was just
gonna be our little fun we'll watch
tiger king and then we'll be back oh and
here we are
we're like what happened we all you know
what it's like it's like we all got
stuck in our house
and then someone like a giant came all
these giants came and grabbed it where
everybody was and they shook the house
they just shut the [__] house and
they set the house back down and then
we're all coming out like
what the [__] was that yeah that was two
years the shaking was two years i just
got shook for two [__] years and i
don't know where i am i don't know what
i'm supposed to do i don't know how i'm
supposed to exist i don't know how to
talk to people well especially as a
stand-up comedian having your world stop
for so long i [__] loved it
i mean i want to get your take on that
now because now that the la comedy scene
is rebuilding from the pandemic
all you know like what how is it
different now i feel like it was so
different before like it was based
around rogan and then rogan left
all the the pandemic just
shook up the etch sketch board like
you're saying
and it's like ooh etch-a-sketch good
different playing field now moving into
i feel like this new
chapter of comedy and like
i don't know it's just it's different
people are putting out specials
different yeah the whole like
i don't know like what's the vibe at the
clubs at the comedy store like does it
how does it feel to you now i think it's
still
it's evolving
i think it's always gonna be an evolving
thing and i see what you're saying i see
how you would think i don't think it all
revolved around joe i think joe
definitely brought energy to him because
he's such a a presence
and um you know an interesting human
being but he came he
came into the scene so the scene was
already there it was already a thing i
think it's evolved along the heels of
of technology and social media that
dictates so much now
because the audience is there and the
audiences are indulging in these shorter
little bits so it's
it's a little bit harder i think more
challenging to maintain
an audience's um attention
so that part changes but now that joe's
in in texas i think it's interesting
if people
haven't to me i think i think it's all
about how you perform
i truly believe in your conviction as a
performer
what you're able to get away with i
don't think that's the right
set of words but what you're able to
like enjoy or at least deliver to your
audience really depends on you
yes and what you put out and how you
portray yourself and how comfortable you
are on stage and what your intention is
and and that sort of can create the
energy of the room that's at least how i
like to perform and what i enjoy the
most is like
let's come i'm gonna [__] around i'm not
here to hurt your feelings
i'm here to let you know that what
you're laughing at is an emotional
connection and what triggers you is
emotional connection
but the trigger is something you gotta
work on
not you don't take down the comedian for
triggering you you should thank a person
who triggers you it's an opportunity for
growth
so we would look at it that's what i
think
so i like to have fun with everybody i
don't want to go up like it's
if someone books me for a show they know
how i am
i'm i'm
unpredictable
big energy big energy fun yeah and love
i come from love
so that's different than coming from a
place of like i'm so [__] cool
everybody laugh at me and come cheer me
yeah that's
that's the difference to me you know
what i mean that is that's i mean it's
like you can there's a lot of comedians
that are in it for the attention yeah
well that's where you have to like it
i think everybody's in it for the
attention
every and ever you look at what's going
on in the world everybody wants
attention but but with comedians is a
different thing
literally the whole point is the
attention
and i had this conversation myself
recently because i'm you know maturing
and i had to ask myself like why did i
get into comedy
and why do i want to stay in it
and
initially like yeah it's like i wanted
the attention it was like a connection
it's like you want the attention then
the attention is creating a connection
and then you're like oh this is a vessel
for something different this is really
cool and an opportunity to like make a
real difference in people's lives making
people forget about their relationship
with the class
with the audience and that in that
moment but then i had to really like ask
myself like
i don't need i don't need that
anymore not anymore but i i guess my
whole
point in life now is to connect and give
not take and receive does that make
sense totally that's what i was trying
to get to yeah that that's like the
difference in what you're expressing is
i'm getting up here to say something to
kind of like
make my continue my relationship with
the fans and add into it and it's not
about
i just want the spotlight on me because
i'm so cool and i want you guys to buy
my merchant [__] it's about a real give
and take yeah that's where i feel like
at coming out of the pandemic it's the
comedians the performers that can really
do that that are the ones that are gonna
push forward yeah authenticity i think
is
um
invaluable
you cannot manufacture it
you can't
um
you have to let it
be what it is
authenticity isn't something that you
can
sort of
create
as a product does that make sense again
you have to embody it
and i think a lot of us i don't know
about you but coming out of the
quarantine like
all the [__] that you went through and
whatever your own individual struggles
were really made you like
go oh i i don't give a [__] about all
this other stuff isn't that crazy that's
exactly how i thought too it's like
shaking off barnacles you were like what
is this [__] on me i told i told rosie
of the day like
you're during that made me think of what
do i really need i need to help
[__] around me
get [__] done
work i don't need i don't it kind of
when everybody was in the same position
during quarantine everyone's [__]
nervous and everyone's like yo is the
world [__] over yeah everyone thought
of i don't care what you're wearing i
don't care how cool you are like my
grandma's sick like i need [__] to do i
need to send food to my [__] family i
need to send money here or
it really put in perspective of holy
[__] i've been
doing the wrong thing i feel yeah i've
been searching for the wrong [__] and
then when it happened
everything worked like yep during
quarantine is when i realized oh i'm
doing the wrong thing put my energy to
something else and now everything we do
is just
[__] working like it never has yep
and it wasn't a thing of how can i make
this work it was just you know let me do
what i want to do and that is what
turned out to be the most lucrative
thing yeah it's always going to be
that's weird
i think if people can find and that's
great like
most people don't have
the
ability to have this space
to create space to receive that for
themselves because their lives are so
chaotic and they're struggling and
they're living from a place of survival
all of that creates such a dust around
your own existence and your own
awareness of yourself
so to be able to like sort of slow down
and let that [__] settle and you're like
oh
i can see through this now i know what i
need i know what i want
and you find
your calling or you find what your
purpose is and i think every human being
wants two things i think for the most
maybe three love
for sure
discovery
you know we have this like um
unwavering desire for discovery you know
out into the outer space and we're
digging we're just looking we're trying
to expand our environment
and i also think that we want purpose we
want to know what our purpose is
and that being like why am i here what
am i meant for
and most people live lives that don't
allow them to just to
have those be readily available in front
of them
to where they can even just look at it
and know it's a thing
so it's good that you discovered that
for yourself and look what it's created
[__] fun life should be [__] fun
no and you see it and i can see by the
way you're saying that you can see in
other people when they can't see with
themselves
it's the worst like i've been talking to
marty a lot like my [__] dad
like he's just struggling right now like
he's just not liking his situation right
now but he's still work does his thing
he's not like he's
yo i'm i'm running out of money it's not
like that it's more of like i'm [__]
over truck even charging he's 15. my
dad's
truck driver yeah wow so he had kids at
15 16. oh my gosh and he might have like
more little sisters and brothers they're
like 16 17 15.
like dad you've worked
you worked all through a kid you had a
kid you've worked since
you're still here like you've never once
done anything for yourself so when i see
that my dad can't you just like take a
step back and see like
you don't have to truck drive that do
what you want i want to open a [__]
pizza shop like he's been saying this i
was a kid so that me and him are opening
blaze pizza we're trying to [__] open
one yeah
yeah we're gonna open one of merced or
like next to merced that's so awesome
you know what i mean that makes me happy
for you i'm so excited because i see him
like he's gonna [__] love that i'm
gonna eat some it's my favorite food
yeah really i'll pay for it who the [__]
doesn't want that [__] like daddy just
make sure you want to do it all day stay
simple
i can order a business mom like yeah see
now you that's awesome
but now i can see it now that i'm past
that point i'm like dad you're not there
how can i you know what i mean like
you're saying like wish people could see
it past and through the [__] but i
finally can yeah our environment and our
culture
makes it so it's difficult
to even be aware
to that
of what you want
to even be aware
people people they're not you know think
about like
in a day
isn't it cool to discover new [__] isn't
it cool to work on what you're meant for
isn't it cool to feel love
most people go through the day and don't
experience that
one of them two of them are all three
and those are to me the fundamentals of
human beings those are the fundamentals
of
like our inner working
what keeps us moving like on a vibrating
level
if you don't have those
of course you're not gonna look a
certain way or feel a certain way you're
a [__] lab rat exactly you're the
non-playable characters in video games
you're the guys in the background
just doing [__] you're the extras in the
movie yeah you're in your own movie
you're [__] extra in your own movie
and we accept that
that's a that's that's the way i always
see it like you're just going through
the motions what do you do when you go
to sleep do you think of stuff like do
you wake up and dream about [__] like
what do you do
not like dream while you're sleep when
you wake up and dream about [__] is what
i really mean yes
most people i talk to like oh i feel bad
i feel so bad for you like i wish you
it's like the truman show and all you
guys are just actors or something like
you need to [__] be truman or
something i know i always feel even
weird talking about like my life in that
way because it's like i don't know what
the answer is for everybody
i just know i don't know it's like
as a
like
a professional entrepreneur through the
internet a professional artist it's like
that's that worked for me that's what
inherently was in me but
and i want to encourage other people to
try to find that within themselves but
it's just like i don't know if i'm or
were people just get lucky like or does
that lie within each of us is there
something i think so to tap into i think
luck really
like using that
term
um
takes away from all the work
you know it's what is it preparation and
opportunity i'll accept it if it's
preparation and opportunity yeah i don't
know
you know
you're just so [__] lucky sometimes i
say that a lot because i'm like how did
i [__] smoke weed for a living i fell
into it but like no i
worked 20 hours of [__] day editing
and doing this for 10 years and doing
this
so in my head i even said damn i got
lucky but it's really you're saying
fortunate
there i'm going to start using
fortunately we're grateful
if you say lucky
this is i like that better when you say
i'm so lucky you're you're saying life
is happening to you
something happened to you i'm so lucky
but if you say i'm so grateful
then life is happening for you
i learned that from tony robbins people
think either life is happening to them
or for them and your mentality
really
wavers on those two things and when it's
happening for you you have this like
openness and gratitude for it and if
it's happening to you you have this
combative
fearful
woe is me i'm a victim mentality i'm not
causing
yeah it's happening to me
so
that's why i've decided in my mind to
stay away from saying i'm so lucky to
i'm so grateful i love it because i say
it all the time damn i'm lucky i feel
like you're so [__] i am
but also like i've done so much [__] to
do it
so you're right i'm fortunate the
opportunities were there great yeah the
[__] is working you're grateful for it
because it's it's
it's all happening
and gratitude is you accepting and
receiving it
luck is like oh oh my gosh thank you
thank you like yeah but
this is a symbiotic relationship you're
having with your own life
and to know that it's like something
that is this
has a ebb and flow to it you're more
connected to it as opposed to it being
like i'm lucky
just by chance just bite you what
there's no connection there
it's like tossing a coin in a fountain
yeah yeah i like this this is this is uh
it started off high as [__] and got
really really
profound yeah and i want to add to it
yesterday i thought i ran over a child
because you said wait for the podcast
and i'll tell you what happened
since we're onto deep profound thoughts
i thought i just murdered a kid
yesterday
you didn't i didn't
thankfully thankfully i'm leaving the
parking lot i got i just got a new car
and i was telling you yeah we were
complaining about our cars yeah i'm like
how do you like your car when you pulled
up and this is how we got in the
conversation so i'll tell you what
happened i'm leaving a parking lot i'm
going seven
barely and the brakes just lock up and
the sensors go off i'm like oh my
[__] god there's a kid under my car a
kid ran from under or something and i'm
thinking
i'm [__] high this is not good i
didn't hit a kid i'm paying attention
but the court's gonna go you were high
wait a minute i wasn't high in driving
you're [__] tripping i was in the
passenger seat i was like yo i thought i
ran over this kid
anyway
anyway it stopped the car turned off and
the car's at the mercedes right now
because i dropped off like hey
second time my car has shut off on me
what if i'm on the freeway next time
yeah dude
take your car fix it fix it or i need
all my money back yeah i need all my
money back and also uh some therapy
sessions for that ptsd ghost child that
i imagined it was a ghost it was casper
and that's really how he got that's sad
i'm gonna hit again i was so scared
because i just dropped off rosie and her
nephew a little kid
i was like oh my god i saw him across
the street though i swear to god like
the first thing i thought was like did i
just [__] hear him
because i backed up super slow i cares
i'm looking like there's no way
that's possible to hit a kid like that
yeah with the sensors it's beeping it's
stuck i know you can't even park your
car no it's hard to stop me
[Music]
damn it's a shrub
it's a shrub yes that's what it is
[__] shrub dude i feel so
scared it's so wild it's like
[Music]
that's what happened so mercedes we
needed to get it the [__] together
because bro get your [__] your child
censorship for real fix your child
sensors just scared me to death keep
your massaging seats till we get the
[__] car to stay on as i don't hit a
child i know they make the seats way too
comfortable actually mine aren't that
comfortable massage seat sounds nice
nice i might just
these things are like you get at the
cairo they [__] do the whole body
yeah this [__] that car is cool
okay hold on yeah podcast yes sharp tug
sharp tongue
what does it drop for everyone out there
that weekend it shifted a little because
i had covet and i didn't consider it
still is
has shifted because
actually this is like the first full
podcast i've actually been able to do
since yeah and like talk and not feel
like i'm [__] about it
what did you do to pass the time
i just netflix
just watch netflix like oh my god i
[__] love virgin river never see that
sounds like
virgin river is amazing the bear have
you watched the bear on hulu are you
watching outdoor [__] only
have you guys seen earth
that's good too
no for real earth is dope
one strange
but um what else did i watch i wat the
bear is a good show
it's a it's about a cook
in in chicago oh it's like a documentary
no it's it's a written it's a ceo it's
really good
um yellowstone
never seen i've watched that never seen
it i like the intro do you like outdoors
and trees i guess i do yeah i'm a nature
the bear i'm a nature lover for sure
yeah yeah yeah um
and i couldn't read it was like you
really i went through too many shows
when i was healthy so now i'm gonna like
start saving them for when i'm sick
because there wasn't a lot not that
there was a lot of available but all
like the really good ones i'd already
have you seen handmaid's tell i'm living
it
have you seen the supreme court
okay so you've seen it good
have you seen my womb because apparently
i can't
i can't even look at my own room and
some of these oh it's good
i was gonna say i feel like
that one five seconds
exchange right now you can't
no i mean like for my process like open
my phone just play you see
i'm living it
i wish it was my race channel
that was i just thought about it like
i'm living you're right
it's come to life coming right now how
crazy that the book went to a show went
to life
wow
wow and it was supposed to be just you
know like this dystopian ah what other
books and [__] i wish come to life
chronicles and hernia i would love to
ride a lion i have never seen it i've
never seen it
and and the book lion wins the wardrobe
all those books
i predicted lionel
hello you open the door and he's like
you know it kind of does sound like a
[__] group from the 50s well um
i'm saying i pretended to read this i've
never seen those um chronicles and arnie
is really good what have you seen uh
what's the other uh lord of the rings i
i've watched them once as a child oh so
i don't think you'd be into that [__]
i've never really seen him
i i'm down
but i've never really i don't watch the
star wars
simple i can't follow him it's gotta be
so that's a lot it's gotta be a white
dude a black dude talking about
basketball yep i'm with you white men
can't jump it's got to be that or juice
i'm still with you yep we're good yeah
marty only watches i love it i can tell
you marty's discography and
whole
movie listen like [__] i wake up i own
them all on dvd yeah what do you watch
just all the real obvious classics he's
furious you're nerd like star wars and
all that [__] [__] no i've never seen
anything
why'd you get something that's just the
opposite of what i watch my [__] is all
in the training day pulp fiction
demographic academy okay so you like
like more action [__] yeah training is
good that denzel washington i'm really
more in that i also lean heavy in the
jim carrey chris farley kind of era too
but then i lean heavy into the juice
above the rim menace to society earlier
so yeah you do have like a really good
it's eclectic but very classic classic
eclectic
straight 90s basically yeah anything
before so many good movies we had so
many like iconic we talk about this
every shot yeah this was the best deck
who do you think who would you say
are the top two like actors from that
era arnold schwarzenegger's number one
he's the biggest one wow
i don't think of him as a 90s dude all
the terminators
okay i guess well
one terminator okay there's one
terminator there's true lies there's
jingle all the way twins well i think
that was like 80. okay
i wanted why did you just air guitar 89
oh i don't know i didn't even know
i think that was like 89. i don't even
know if this is a guitar i don't know
you just created like a [__] new
instrument it's from star wars
that [__] in the beginning if you would
have watched it that's when the aliens
are [__] playing the kazoos it's so
interesting like
a person's idea of like who the iconic
actor is is really based off their own
personal experience like for me it's jim
carrey yeah i grew up in a comedy
household yeah it's just curious leo
it's denzel
it's [__] tom hanks
um
tom hanks wow saying crushed it who
crushed in one oscar female we can't
even think of a female of the 90s yeah
you know i had another you got karen and
goodfellas you brought this
it was in the sopranos and that was it
both of those that was it
i brought it we gotta google it
i'm gonna i can't yeah go
what do you think about jennifer lopez
well i want to know what you think
because i feel like can i tell you what
i think i think you have a very strong
opinion about her and you want to know
if mine matches it no i want to know if
yours is opposite
can we just say that
no she imagined it i don't know it's the
opposite
i have a feeling
i have a feeling that she has an opinion
on jayla yes i don't know why because i
know you're you're like oh brad pitt's
my guy i haven't heard you talk about
too many actresses how do you feel about
jennifer i honestly am so
impressed with her okay i'm impressed
with what she's done where she came from
and what oh that's great how she
continues
to
stay relevant
and it seems seamless and i don't know
at what cost
i can't imagine
oh my gosh no i don't even mean it as
like shade i mean to stay relevant no no
i know what you're saying i'm just
saying like damn you thought this
through i was just gonna say how many
times you gonna get married on a movie
marry me listen
she's got like 30 movies in a row he's
like i'm a bride again i work for myself
gotcha oh it's her life
every [__] movie she might as well be
steven seagal but
she makes the same [__] movie every
four months
no marrying me was different i didn't
watch it but i just saw the i i just
seen it it's so funny
yeah and it seems like it's life
imitating our imitating life
and now she's back with ben affleck i
don't know how you can like it's 1999
it's it's 1999 again it is it really is
19.99
will smith smack the [__]
[__]
i was gonna ask that was the craziest
thing i ever saw and also chris rock
loved his reaction look classy
i thought it was like this
there's a slow kid just making fun of me
and everybody's making fun of me dude
that's the reaction like i'm embarrassed
but i don't know if i should be
embarrassed i was just so shocked that
it was a real moment the first two weeks
after that i was so just like there's no
way that could have like not been
planned you've seen it i thought it was
i thought it was planned for a second
yeah just because how he dips so
perfectly with once you back up a little
bit like hey i know i'm supposed to back
up when motherfucker's approaching me
well if they come out with a movie we're
gonna be like these are the [__] like
the chickens
in like the next six seven months or
like these [__] that was great
i mean we've all lost our mind and it
doesn't
success doesn't make you impervious to
anything yeah well of course because
when you're under a [__] spotlight
the whole world whether regardless if
you put yourself under that spotlight or
not it's still pressure yeah it's still
like everybody's watching me i don't
know what the [__] to do type of [__]
but for i mean i'm sure people have
listened to the subject at exhaust but
still
for will smith you talked about i don't
think really
i just think like
i i don't know
it was such a crazy moment it really
just was so insane to see that
happen and for will smith to like put an
apology video out
i didn't even know that happened he put
an apology video out he would have been
better off doing six minutes on his
insight timer
meditating instead of putting some
self-congratulatory
probably fake [__]
apology video out i don't i don't even
know you're the fresh prince of bel-air
why do i know this much about you mm-hmm
that's what i was gonna say why are you
on instagram parents don't understand
and yo why do you clap a little chris
rock
wait why do you guys know that what are
you talking about i'm just i'm i'm
speaking to you next slide you talked
about the apology video well read red
topic
is too much information we know too much
about these people why you shouldn't
yeah i got you and
coming out of quarantine
will smith is a human being he's not
impervious to what that does to your
soul and spirit and it comes out of
quarantine who knows what's going on in
his relationship we know too much about
what's going on in his relationship and
he he's not you know he's a human being
he's flawed and yeah i'm not excusing
his behavior but i'm saying like
bro be a legend like you said it
yourself i am [__] legend be a
[__] legend and just chill the [__]
out
wow dagger vance
all right cool yeah like you got to be
like you got it what's the case oh
that's just nice yeah you gotta make
that [__] fancy it looks like a older
older man it's like a vampire guard
that's what she thought when she got it
because it matches her all her jewelry
one of my best friends justin martindale
and i do that to each other all the time
all the time it's a game we've been
playing for eight years
where we'll just catch each other off
guard one time and you'll just be like
talking and then you look over and it's
like
oh my god we're the girls the ring the
girl in the closet from the ring oh
yeah the girl all shriveled up amber i
think it was amber what's her name damn
the ring you remember like that yeah oh
wow [__] [__] me up japanese river
ghost [__] japanese river ghosts come
crawling out of the thing dude i was
just talking about that movie nope
look i can't wait don't don't say
anything but the fact that you just made
up a [__] name like that like yo i
made up a name too about that movie
justin you let me know
i'm gonna go see nope this weekend yeah
i won't say anything about it because i
don't read reviews i mean you don't know
we're huge people
either i just went to watch it and i
heard nothing about it oh okay yeah i
didn't even get your review yet did i no
no yeah i'm gonna go see it and we'll
we'll talk
but you i feel like dope
and nope there could have been something
there i just did my damn story time
about [__] ufos and lined up
perfectly with this movie perfect
i couldn't you call it nope dope no fog
it's called ufos that's still cool
but no for merced there's hell of [__]
merced i don't know what it is and then
somebody in my comments last night
there's a lot of sightings in the
central valley right side eczema
i'm just going off what i hear i want to
make sure i'm not hearing it wrong it's
good i'm on shrooms i got half a can
because i'm okay i'm in and out of
reality here and i heard
that's what i heard i don't know why
you're so all over the place with your
topics we were talking about ufos
you were not there's
sightings in the central valley
that's the words
[Laughter]
you know somebody brought it up there's
an air force base two miles from my
grandma's i forgot it they're testing
[__] it's been there since the 60s and
we have all the planes and the jets how
did i forget
well that's probably why there's so much
weird stuff in the valley we have an air
force base in merce like in merced
anyway i seen some scary [__] one time
uh
i i i'll just tell you this quick
version i was my grandpa we went to
rachel nevada it's like an alien citing
towns where people go to like try to
catch stuff on camera so my grandpa took
me i was eight i go to the bathroom in
this town of eight dudes just drinking a
beer in the day
you know those like the towns were two
on food things for everything that's the
town i went to basically
just like that like a couple dudes and
i'm in the bathroom they have pictures
of alien sightings all over the wall i
go to the bathroom
i'm calling about my kid
i look out the window and i know what i
saw i told my grandpa i saw this [__]
like almost full triangle thing like
well now what i look like it's probably
one of those those triangle jets that we
see on the news yeah the ones that we
stealth fighters that we see yeah and
some of them are drones i didn't know
but this was like 1997 right and i see
it whipping i'm mid [__] as an
eight-year-old midloaf slicing it yep i
get up immediately scream right pinch
the loaf
sorry i didn't even see i went real far
you missed it projected you're right so
you pinch the loaf ran out and screamed
there's a ufo outside in the restaurant
that we were in and everyone in the
restaurant followed me oh i thought
you're gonna say they came because they
were like this is over time
this is our moment
that would be a different story that's
so [__] up this is why there's
parental guidance on this i'm sorry it's
okay did i turn your ch children's show
to an adult show no it was a cool show
this is a kids show would you say cherry
would you call them earlier cherry
that's what you're on
i'm taking this home with me i have to
leave you guys yeah i know we need like
three hours you're at one last time was
like what three twenty barely passed the
intro here i know technically i didn't
even start i didn't even say anything
yeah you said one you gotta be out here
one fourth yeah cool so good timing good
for being on this on the time because i
i tried to be no you're great i haven't
checked in like 40 minutes and i just
looked what is it it's 3 30 i mean it's
1 30. three i'm like
no you're good very good yeah take that
joint i'm keeping this yeah i didn't
realize you would be on mushrooms so no
i i enjoy it a little bit you know cause
there's ways i have to get back
she's not driving she took an uber and
all they talked about her car pulled up
i was lying i have a driver she's a
driver outside he's 90. private security
team at the door yeah it's one of the
ladies that marty didn't get
the lady from the store it's like it's
the cold ghost who hopped in the front
seat of his caprice [__] the cold ghost
i never considered it could have been a
[__] ghost marty's basically the kid
from forrest gump i'm not supposed to
get in cars or strangers
that's you here he's the kid from the
sixth sense
hayley washington everything i see
she said some [__] that's right put the
blanket over my head i was so scared as
a kid because her mother was munch
housing her by proxy munch housing
by proxy all of the same thing as eczema
on the hillside huh
didn't know what i said to judges
it doesn't feel good
[Music]
don't
don't stop
[Applause]
you can't sneak up he did scare me
though i almost i almost screamed during
the josh episode oh my gosh
we had a son too and his son is like 6
10. love him
oh my god we stood up and we were on
trooms he looked like the dude from
[__] night before before christmas
the check
carla i used carlisle yes
the guys
that's his nickname that's what josh
calls him really his name is jake jake
wolfe he's great he's awesome he's so
he's so she's just like his dad and he's
yeah he's just fun he's like yeah
you make me feel small he definitely
looks like a gucci model or something
yeah okay yeah he does like a high-end
fashion model bro yeah listen
josh is in town for a month there's no
way we we have to do another episode
with all three of us and we all have to
do shrooms oh my god but marty has to
have restricted i'm the designated i i'm
the restricted do you drive in this oh
yeah
[Applause]
i'm about to sample that chair
should be my laughs
we'll text it to you just look up tan
mom give yourself five minutes
and thank me later i know she is oh you
do everybody's heard a song
that's stuck on the bottom of your oven
let's go that's that upstate new york
quickness thank
but is it bad i still want to grill
cheese that's the best part that's the
best part yeah i'm really mad you guys
don't have you should have a grilled
cheese oven forever what do you mean
look no i'm scared it's a chair
if there was a grilled cheese station
i'm sorry there's not i'm surprised
there's nothing i can't have walls like
this and no grilled cheese don't worry
next time i i won't have it either you
can't have walls like this with no
grilled cheese it's
a hot dog cart
ain't got a popcorn machine yeah we had
the food truck out front when you pulled
up we don't have a popcorn that's a good
[__] idea yeah you got it a popcorn
machine and you scoop it
yeah yeah we're supposed to leave we're
supposed to leave you have to leave
where can everybody find you at where
you on instagram on youtube
shark tongue podcast
um
i also have girl gyrl as a podcast
that's what i wanted to pick up but it's
a fun one
a lot of advice we talk about our
relationships on there like our personal
relationships and dates and then there's
the juice it gets real [__] it gets very
annoying
people have to pay to listen to it
that's my that's how i validate just
just you know just sort of dishing my
[__]
[Laughter]
ruining my significant other's lives oh
my gosh i think about stuff i've said on
there and i'm like maybe i should make
that
maybe we should take it down
um
what else do i have
her and i are on tour in the fall
on tour yeah we're doing shows we're
gonna be in florida chicago brooklyn
um
other major cities jessemay.com for
tickets when does that start that starts
september through november and it's me
and carly aquilino nice so marty's got
these new cool overlays so boom boom
just brought it up right there there
yeah and then i also have another
podcast called the deuce with my boy the
dudes the deuce yeah we just nerd out we
snored out on topics and
when would you start this in quarantine
both of those were started in quarantine
see we haven't we haven't seen i know we
need to see posts we see each other's
posts i know i know it's like a it's
like a
cliff notes to each other's lives
but now we know we've learned we need
hours prolific and [__] yeah like last
time was yeah we would have went four
[__] hours
that's right it was like over three
hours was it three something left yeah
yeah because i remember making a comment
like it felt like rogan yeah it was
forever and then right after you left
and we did another three and a half
right after you left matalon so it was
the next
hour
i was so [__] high oh my god
because i just did it again like all
over all of you know you love it it was
great that's why it's successful
because you love it and love permeates
all of it
love is the source of anything
successful
so that's we're going to take out of
this one hell yeah and if you can take a
step back and look through the [__]
and see what you really need what's
really important i love all of that all
that talk i feel like somebody
out there is like [__] needed that
[__] today i'm glad we could bring this
happens i feel like it always like hit
somebody at the right time so whoever it
was i'm [__] happy for you what
happened because i'm gonna need that
yeah all right mario got anything else
thank you justin
thank you marty appreciate it
fans have been asking for this uh i love
i love your fans you guys have a great
thing here everybody's so [__] fun
and they're vulgar and [__] so we're
fine perfect no one's ever been attended
i don't care if i you judge me if you
want no one's ever said anything on the
i do all the comments
everyone loved it not one person what's
up with this ball grass light nothing
nothing watch watch oh this is what i
said
it's the lady that picked marty up
look at this boy i was gonna kill you
that night i wish i would have killed
you guys i should have killed you when i
had the change
large marge
eileen warnos
you probably have eileen warno's the
tournament
that's the woman who killed all those
men oh you probably escaped eileen or
nothing i thought you just made
yeah that's what i'm gonna tell
everybody so you can tell your grandkids
well this is delightful thank you so
much for being here thanks appreciate it
thanks for ruining brad pitt for me it's
okay just think of it every time you
sleep
all right thank you for being here
appreciate it i gotta get out of here
thanks for cam uh for coming thanks for
hanging out marty appreciate you thank
you thank you for being here and
everybody out there thank you for
hanging out thank you for being in the
chat have a dope as day all right
oh yeah i know you're high but i got a
bunch of edibles and stuff so yeah we'll
give you for later
[Music]